why do you feel that now is the right
time in your career to take the sleep of
faith and join the celebrity big brother
world
i just finished 11 years of doing the
real housewives of atlanta i had such an
amazing time on
that show and this is my next chapter so
all i really wanted all i really prayed
for my next chapter was to
be able to continue to be on tv and to
have fun
well hello celebrity big brother it's
television and it's fun so
thank you god for making my dream come
true
yes
and as a celebrity you're accustomed to
people watching your every move and
living under a microscope are you ready
for the public to see you in a different
light watching you 24 7.
i'm used to being on camera i'm used to
people
seeing me on tv
all the time from the real housewives of
atlanta however i'm not used to people
seeing me on a live feed sleeping at
night i'm not used to people watching me
sleep i'm really really not used to that
and
you know i'm a woman of a certain age so
i'm going through
pre-menopause right now
and what happens with that i get hot i'm
cold so you know i have clothes on i
take clothes off like and i'm not even
conscious that i'm doing these things
while i'm sleeping so hopefully
you know the fans don't get a little bit
more than they bargained for watching me
sleep i mean
everyone's seeing my breasts on the real
housewives balance like i'm always
having a nip slip so
everyone's seen my breasts on the real
housewives balance i'm always having a
nip slip like even on the girls trip the
ultimate girl strip i had a nip slip so
yes people have seen me partially you
know naked before but not full
and hopefully
i won't uh hopefully hopefully that
won't happen
awesome and this next question i feel
like you kind of just answered but i'm
just going to ask it again okay canada
what part of yourself are you most
scared or embarrassed for the public to
see example no makeup or glam grumpy in
the morning addicted to coffee okay
the only thing that i'm really concerned
about people seeing
you know you got to realize i came from
the real housewives balana so you guys
have seen me with me cup without makeup
mika see me happy singing sad you see me
cry you've seen me do everything
the only thing that i'm concerned about
is
the fact that
you know
i am
going through pre-menopause
which is something that you really don't
want to do with a group full of people
that you don't know with a house full of
people that you don't know so
i don't know what the temperatures are
in the house but i'm hot i'm cold like
i'm just all over the place i have mood
swings because of you know pre-menopause
like i'm a hot mess like no pun intended
and sometimes a coldness
whatever
and then last one who would you not want
to see walk through the doors of the
celebrity big brother house
oh lord
[Laughter]
okay
i don't want to call names but there's a
couple of people that i would not want
to see walk through the doors of the big
brother house
i'm just i said i was not going to be
messy i am not going to call any names
but they know who they are they know who
they are and i really really pray that
they do not
walk through the doors at least not
while i'm in the house